I'm Charles Payne I'm Kat timpf I'm
Stuart Vonnie and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday March 22nd 2023
I'm Dave Anthony
former president Trump May soon be
indicted in New York City by a
progressive district attorney who claims
it's not political if this was anyone
other than Donald Trump
Bragg would not be bringing this case
I'm Lisa Brady as Russia and China put
up a united front the U.S armed forces
try to put up better numbers 2023 is the
crunchier for military recruiting for
sure and I'm Ian Pryor I've got the
final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
president Trump it's the same old same
old just a continuation of the most
disgusting Witch Hunt in the history of
our country posting on Truth social
about an investigation in New York City
into something that happened before he
was elected it's an absolute disgrace
what's going on but this time he appears
closer than ever to becoming the first
president current or former to be
criminally charged
those are anti-trump protesters
chanting in diet indict and no one is
above the law
outside the office of Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg a progressive
Democrat who has a grand jury probing
the hush money payment to adult film
star Stormy Daniels prior to the 2016
presidential election as a possible
campaign Finance violation keeping her
quiet about her claims of a past Affair
Trump lawyer Elena Haba says this is a
politicization politicization of our
justice system and I think it's a
frightening time for our country frankly
if Michael Cohen is a key witness as
we're hearing Bragg's office claims this
is not politics Cohen is the former
Trump lawyer or fixer as he's been
called who orchestrated that hush money
payment then later went to prison for
tax evasion and campaign Finance law
violations his former advisor a trump
Ally Robert Costello testified to that
same grand jury to contradict Cohen and
then told Fox I wouldn't touch a witness
like Michael Cohn for any amount of
money you simply cannot rely upon this
guy Colin Kona fire on a revenge tour
but as soon as today or maybe next week
an indictment may be coming you know
this idea that President Trump would be
arrested which actually is a is a notion
that he promoted is really not accurate
Andrew McCarthy is a former Federal
prosecutor now a Fox News contributor
because we're talking about a
non-violent crime and there's good
reason to wonder whether it's a crime at
all but let's assume for argument's sake
that it is uh it's certainly non-violent
so I anticipate what would happen if an
indictment is returned by the grand jury
is that an arrangement will be made will
former president Trump to come to
Manhattan and surrender basically he
won't be handcuffed on the street
they'll make an arrangement where he'll
go to basically to the courthouse uh the
New York City Police will have people
there who can process him which means he
would be fingerprinted and photographed
like anybody else who comes into the
system he'll be presented before a judge
he might enter a plea at the first
proceeding it's typical to enter a not
guilty plea after you've been indicted
and then the case Dave will get assigned
to a trial judge who will set a schedule
for pre-trial motions and will be Off to
the Races the charge in this case
what would it be if there is an
indictment what is the charge
so we hear that the main part of this
case the gravaman of the case as they
say in the law is the Stormy Daniels
hush money agreement
and in a nutshell they paid her a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
keep quiet about an affair she claims to
have had with Donald Trump in around
2006 2007 he denies that she says it
happened uh it really doesn't matter
whether it happened or not uh in terms
of what the charge is likely to be which
is the falsification of business records
the payment itself
was from then Trump associate lawyer
Michael Cohen a hundred thirty thousand
dollars for the non-disclosure agreement
so quiet sir keeps her quiet before the
2016 presidential election
then
Michael Cohen gets paid back for the
money that he paid and that's where we
are right that it's all about how that
repayment was classified right yeah
that's exactly right it's it as
succinctly as I can put it this was a
reimbursement of a debt that was
incurred in October of 2016 and in their
books the Trump organization and Donald
Trump who were kind of conflated for
these purposes
they booked it as if they were paying
Cohen legal fees throughout 2017. so
it's it's made in the books to look like
it's a payment of legal fees over 12
months but it's in fact reimbursement
for the debt incurred the reason that
this becomes relevant is because what
we've just described is falsification of
business records is a misdemeanor under
New York law the only way it becomes a
felony is if the prosecutor can prove
Beyond a reasonable doubt that they
defendant intended to conceal the
commission of another crime
in falsifying the business records
um so the question is what other crime
could conceivably have been being
covered up and would that be the
campaign contribution that he says was
unreported yeah that's what you're what
you're pointing out is the crime that
most of the educated speculation
figures that Bragg is going to say Trump
was concealing he's got big problems
trying to do that first the campaign
Finance laws of federal
when the New York statute about
falsifying business records when it
talks about concealing and other crime
that's a quote from the statute another
crime uh they're obviously talking about
a New York crime and the campaign
Finance laws in a presidential election
are the federal laws so he shouldn't be
able to vindicate federal law in a state
prosecution he doesn't have jurisdiction
to do that and it's important to point
out Dave that most campaign Finance
violations they're typically handled by
allowing the candidate or the campaign
to pay a fine to the election
authorities so this is not something
that's typically handled as a felony
prosecution I just don't see how that
that could be the other crime that he's
talking about okay now obviously
Republicans are accusing this Democratic
district attorney in Manhattan Alvin
Bragg of being political I want you to
hear from Jim Jordan he chairs the house
Judiciary Committee he and other GOP
committee chairs have written to brag
they want him to testify about what he's
doing in New York and this is Jordan on
Fox Mr Bragg himself didn't want to
bring the case but then he got pressured
I think from the left and I would say
this the one thing that has changed the
one thing I think has changed his mind
is President Trump announced he was
going to run for president again and the
former president wants Bragg brought up
on some sort of a charge of interfering
with an upcoming presidential election
now Bragg's office says we will not be
intimidated by attempts to undermine the
Justice process and the accusations are
baseless so what's your reply to the
politics that are surrounding the legal
issues well a lot of this rhetoric is
silly you know if we want to be serious
there's no question that what Bragg is
doing here is a naked partisan exercise
he's an elected Progressive Democrat
going after Donald Trump as we've seen
his good politics in in big cities even
if it's atrocious law enforcement but
Andy on the other side of that Bragg
Defenders say that when he took office
he declined to move forward on an
investigation into Trump business
practices which led some prosecutors who
were leading the case to resign from his
office so brag Defenders are saying look
he has credibility because he didn't go
after Trump in that other case so so why
is it politics now this is that case
this is the case that he walked away
from you know with the Democrats and the
people in the DA's office were hoping
was that uh when Bragg's predecessor or
Cyrus Vance went to the Supreme Court
twice to get Trump's Financial records
they were hoping that was going to be
the mother lode of a big financial fraud
prosecution they didn't have enough
evidence for a criminal prosecution
which is why they didn't bring the case
uh Tish James who was the State Attorney
General ended up trying to charge that
as a big civil case we'll have to see
how that all works out but they did it
as a civil case because that's a lower
burden of proof but the fact is the very
case that we're talking about Bragg
dropped a year ago and now is bringing
back I think because number one the
adulation that that Tish James got for
filing the big civil suit against Trump
and number two because one of the
prosecutors who left the office Mark
pomerance ended up writing a book that
is now like bedtime reading for all
progressives called I think the people
against Donald Trump so basically
they've ratcheted up as progressives do
the political pressure on Bragg who is
one of them and the one thing we can say
conclusively is that if this was anyone
other than Donald Trump
Bragg would not be bringing this case
and what Bragg has been notorious for in
his tenure is actually taking serious
felony offenses and degrading them to
misdemeanors or entirely dismissing them
when you're talking about actual
hardened criminals here he's taking
stale nonsense which at best is a
misdemeanor and trying to hyperbolize it
into a felony clearly for political
reasons of course this is just one of
many Trump investigations the justice
department is probing all the classified
documents founded as Florida Resort and
looking into his post 2020 election
conduct leading up to the January 6th
Capitol Riot and then there's the
Georgia investigation into Trump's
attempts to overturn the election
results in that state so there could be
other criminal charges coming I think
that you know the fact that the first
prosecutor crosses the Rubicon kind of
makes it easier for other prosecutors
who may have been worried about the
fraud politics of charging Trump this at
least makes it a little bit easier for
them to go forward so we've had in the
Fulton County Georgia case we had the
four woman of the grand jury come out
and do basically a press tour a few
weeks ago after that grand jury filed
its uh investigative report and she said
that they recommended to the district
attorney that many people be charged and
shoot powerfully uh suggested that the
president or former president Trump was
at the top of the list concurrently we
see that Jack Smith who was the Biden
justice department appointed special
counsel who's looking at both the
Mar-A-Lago documents case and January 6
has stepped up his activity uh and he's
obviously not doing that idly so those
are very serious investigations and they
could well end up in indictments could
be a very interesting 2024 campaign with
all this hanging over his head and he
remains the front runner for the
Republicans yeah well you know the
Constitution says the qualifications for
president are that you have to be 35 and
a natural-born citizen who's lived in
the United States for 14 years
ain't nothing else so if they want to uh
you know the American people want to uh
elect somebody who's under investigation
or someone who's convicted of a crime or
someone who's doing time at Leavenworth
they can do it nothing in the
Constitution says they can't but it's um
it's strange times Andy McCarthy former
assistant U.S attorney for the southern
district of New York and a Fox News
contributor always good to talk to you
thanks a lot thanks Dave
[Music]
this is Ian Pryor with your Fox News
commentary
coming up
China and Russia say they've never been
closer
presidents she and Putin after two days
of meetings in Moscow pledging to deepen
cooperation and expand economic ties
calling each other dear friends we're
not going to get all
hot and bothered about the use of
friends what what we've seen is these
are two countries that are growing
closer together
um that see in each other uh useful
purposes but National Security Council
spokesman John Kirby calls it a marriage
of convenience rather than a true
Alliance and he rejects Russia's
continued claims that its invasion of
Ukraine is defensive for its own
security and that the West is prolonging
the conflict supplying weapons to
Ukraine Mr Putin could stop bombing
hospitals cassette bombing schools he
could stop launching Iranian drones into
civilian infrastructure he could stop
the forcible deportation of young kids
thousands of them putting them in
filtration camps a joint statement from
China and Russia calls for observing the
principles and purposes of the UN
Charter and respecting international law
Kirby says what they really want is for
the world to play by their rules instead
a deepening relationship between two
foreign adversaries at a time of
daunting statistics for the U.S military
the Senate armed services commit
committee holding a hearing today on
recruitment challenges one defense
department study says 80 percent of
Americans ages 17 to 24 are unfit for
military service and the number
interested in serving has been shrinking
military recruiting it's the perfect
storm Rebecca Grant is a national
security analyst and founder of Iris
independent research there's high
employment in the civilian economy
remember the recruiters have not been
out in the high schools as much over the
past two years that's really hurting
them and then there's some bigger
factors only about nine percent of Young
Americans say they would consider
military service on top of that some
issues passing physical fitness tests
and the other standard military test
batteries and it adds up to a really big
problem it's been brewing for quite a
while but it got a lot worse last year I
want to unpack some of that starting
with perception of the military if you
will there was a study last year that
found only 55 percent of Jen's ears have
some or a lot of trust in the military
compared to 86 percent of Baby Boomers
and then you add to that
concerns that military officials have
have raised that they have said may be a
factor including concern among younger
Americans about things like sexual
harassment in the military for instance
or PTSD
how can the military work to counteract
some of these things is is that part of
what's going on
yes and remember world events can really
Drive perceptions of the military so
that after the horrific events of 9 11
there was a big surge in recruiting if
gen Z doesn't feel directly threatened
by Russia or China or Iran or even the
southern border then you've got an issue
in their willingness to serve there's
been a lot of focus by the military on
preventing and diminishing sexual
harassment when that makes the headlines
you know the reality is that the
military is working to improve there but
I can see where that sometimes gets
misunderstood and then add in that we've
had a volunteer Force now for many many
decades and that means that there are
some families out there that just don't
have anybody in the military no
experience of a brother or a sister or
an aunt or a Granddad in the service and
that adds up to that lower propensity to
serve but that's what Recruiters in the
military it's their job to turn that
around and show Young Americans the
opportunities that the services can
provide them
and as you mentioned they've they've not
been able to be at high schools or at
least they weren't you know at the
height of the pandemic so covet
definitely plays a role in in terms of
the Outreach ability in person how much
of the qualifications to serve evolved
over time is it more difficult now to
enlist on the contrary the services
always fluctuate those standards the
Army has set in place a program to help
recruits even before they get to boot
camp so they do more running and
exercises so they're able to meet the
minimum standards and very interesting
the Navy actually just raised the age
for enlisting from 38 all the way up to
41 to try to expand that pool so the
services they need fit individuals
because they have to deploy but they
also really want to meet Americans part
of the way if they're willing to serve
they will help you get through those
Fitness requirements it has been a
problem in the overall population as we
see more breeds of obesity among the
young and other problems that does
affect that pool but the military
services really want to try to get in
there and help you if you want to serve
they don't want to let the physical part
stand in your way what about lowering
standards for enlistment is that
something that's been talked about would
it be too dangerous or you know are
there Common Sense changes that they try
to make over time to help with that
it's just like any recruiting that you
do whether it's for college admissions
or the military you move that bar a
little bit you're always going to have
your minimum standards met but you move
it a little bit on test scores or
physical fitness if you need to take a
bigger group in and all the services say
that they have actually dropped that a
little bit and they're doing some
interesting things like being more
lenient on tattoos a little more lenient
about enlisted personnel who are single
and have a child coming in so they have
some ability to fluctuate the standards
in order to recruit a bigger group
are all of the branches struggling or
some faring better than others
the space force is the huge exception
it's the sixth Branch the newest and
smallest service under 10 000 people but
they are not struggling the space force
is turning away people it is so popular
right up from the enlistees coming out
of high school to mid-career
professionals that are going into the
officer Corps the space force is so
popular it is actually turning recruits
away how does our military
compare to China and Russia at this
point they've increasingly made
themselves you know U.S adversaries on
the world stage I've heard about China
building up its Navy should the U.S be
concerned or more concerned about how
those countries are building their
militaries
well on personnel there is just no
comparison U.S military personnel are
far superior in quality and in training
to anything that Russia and China has on
the equipment and the hardware though
hey that's another story China really
has built up its number of ships and
aircraft they have a big army not as big
as it used to be but still very large
and we know that China and Russia have
been acting much more aggressively
they're also allies now Military Allies
and that military alliance between China
and Russia is very very disturbing and
it means that our U.S military along
with our allies really has to be at the
peak of Readiness and long term that's
why the military has to resolve this
recruiting problem so we can continue to
have the quality best in the world
military members in the U.S in the
meantime we keep sending a lot of
equipment to Ukraine the Pentagon is
planning to speed up delivery of tank to
Ukraine Now by sending an older version
of the Abrams are they just as good in
terms of helping to meet Ukraine's needs
I'm glad that the Abrams tanks are going
over there look we have about 8 000
Abrams in the inventory in various
states of Readiness and it is no problem
to send 31. it's not the latest variant
it's the M1A1 not the m1a2 but believe
me these 31 Abrams Tanks going to
Ukraine are highly capable and they need
to get there right away so that's a good
move so when you talk about several
dozen tanks compared to the thousands
that we have it sounds like we're okay
when it comes to tanks what about the
rest of our stockpiles though the
administration just announced another
drawdown
do we have enough of everything to keep
doing this for Ukraine
we need to keep doing this for Ukraine
and it's no secret that there are parts
of our Munitions industrial base
especially that need to be speeded up
you know we're not depleting U.S
reserves to a dangerous level but there
are areas uh in various types of
missiles and ammunition where we need to
have the Pentagon take the lead with
Congress and go and get some Advanced
longlead funding for our industry to top
that back up but hey you know Ukraine is
getting to I think a pretty critical uh
situation right now and we do at the
moment along with our allies in the 54
countries that are helping out we do
have enough to keep sending it remember
really this was what we invested in
these Munitions for was to protect
democracy and beat back Russia if we had
to so I'm glad the ukrainians are doing
that
in addition to the inherent you know
potential danger of serving of defending
the country how much of an impact can
other health concerns have and I ask
that because of the recent Pentagon
study
finding higher risks of certain kinds of
cancer in military Aviation including
for ground Crews has that been a concern
for a long time Congress authorized this
study and they looked at a million
people who had served in air Crews or
the ground Crews that support the
aviators and found higher incidents of
cancers in a few specific areas melanoma
thyroid cancer and a couple of others I
think this concern was anecdotal and the
study showed that its epidemiological
it's really a valid concern what will
happen now in phase two is Congress has
asked the military to find out why these
rates of cancer are higher among these
Crews and to look at the work
environment and potential hazards it'll
take them some time to uncover that
interesting of course the overall the
aviators in the ground crew are a very
healthy Bunch their overall cancer rates
are lower than the typical population
but they're higher in these specific
areas and on recruiting usually Air
Force Navy Aviation recruiting is
actually one of the easiest of the
billets to fill would you say the
Outlook is getting better or worse right
now in terms of this recruiting issue is
is the military doing enough to try to
turn a corner on it well 2023 is really
going to be the test case the problem is
biggest for the Army they missed by 15
000 recruits last year they want to
actually bring in 65 000 this year
they're going to have to work very very
hard to do that if they missed this
year's goal they've got a real problem
Navy and Air Force they made their
requirements but just barely they also
know they have to start earlier and do
better and I think getting the
recruiters out into the schools and into
the community more things that they
couldn't do during covet hopefully will
make the difference but 2023 is the
crunchier for military recruiting for
sure Rebecca Grant National Security
analyst founder of Iris independent
research thank you so much for your time
thank you
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi do
you think there could be a zombie
apocalypse one day if you do you're one
of 10 Americans that feel that way
according to a new survey but where you
live could impact the likelihood of
survival the success of The Last of Us
on HBO LED Insurance Marketplace
Insurance to ask more than a thousand
Americans about zombies and what they
think they should do if there were to be
a zombie apocalypse they analyzed more
than a thousand Google searches to
determine where each state lands on the
zombie apocalypse preparedness according
to the survey Wyoming is the ready
estate to take on The Walking Dead the
organization says states that aren't
heavily populated and have access to a
lot of open space are the best because
you can live off the land stockpile
weapons and avoid other people Alaska is
your next best bet followed by Vermont
North Dakota and South Dakota the worst
state the Golden State California
Landing in 50th place for where to spend
the end of the world topped by Texas
Florida New York Pennsylvania at the
bottom of the list as for the weapons to
use when fighting off zombies
participants apparently thought about
that already too the number one weapon
they chose to defend themselves was a
shotgun followed by a handgun baseball
bat machete crossbow sword ax knife
grenade and Katana for the Fox News
rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary
what's on your mind this week the
parents Bill of Rights hb5 will be
debated on the floor of the House of
Representatives this bill will help
provide greater transparency in public
schools give parents statutory rights
alongside their constitutional right to
direct the upbringing of their children
and pressure our public education system
to focus on academics instead of social
indoctrination having helped lead the
fight in Loudoun County Virginia it is a
testament to the hard work of parents
that House Republicans have made this a
priority in the new con service this
week I release a new book parents of the
World Unite how to save our schools from
the left's radical agenda in which I
document the successes the parents in
Loudoun County had in shining the
spotlight of accountability on America's
most notorious Public School
administration and School Board story is
told through 12 strategic rules that
helped guide our actions over the past
two years but can also be used to
maximum effect by parents and parent
groups throughout the country these are
those rules
every neighborhood is a battlefield pay
attention to what happens on your street
and in your community the infection of
cancel culture and wokeism is not
limited to the federal government
corporate boardrooms professional sports
or Hollywood but has arrived next door
activate investigate communicate every
parent can be a private investigator
into the moral Corruption of the schools
that they pay for and send their
children to with key tools like the
Freedom of Information Act the
protection of people rights amendment
and targeted media outreach anyone can
start to shine the spotlight of
accountability on their school district
always flip the script with a
combination of fearlessness and humorous
mockery parents can punch through the
far left's most potent psychological
tool fear of cancel culture and bring
the fight to the bullies
identify the bad guys and take it to
them every Conflict by its nature needs
a good versus evil framework is
therefore important to find the right
bad guys to fight
turn your fight into must-see TV the
greatest Generals in history always knew
that there must be an element of
Showmanship to the battle
do not get stuck in the mud always be in
motion the opposition however clumsily
will start to fight back and try to
engage you on their terms do not fall
into the Trap when they Zig you must zag
and keep moving forward to your goal
when they mobilize go gorilla when
you're going up against the status quo
they will find a way to mobilize their
political power and Legacy Media that's
inevitable what's not inevitable is how
you respond when they finally confront
you in the air morph into a guerrilla
operation that Maneuvers on the ground
do not stop at the wall a battle will
have Ebbs and flows and you will find
yourself hitting a wall external and
internal Dynamics will make it
challenging to get past that wall into
the green fields on the other side you
gotta believe be flexible and open to
ideas but never take your eyes off the
North Star and never forget why you
joined the fight in the first place
don't let them off the ropes eventually
your strategies and tactics if well
executed will bring you to a moment when
your opponent is on the ropes they've
made crucial mistakes to be in that
situation when this happens it's not
time to back off go for The Knockout
don't be overly reliant on past success
the greater the success the greater the
dangers that follow complacency will
often set in as will the tendency to
overly rely on the strategies and
tactics that brought Victory eventually
your opponents will adapt and exploit
play the end game always know your end
game what started as your primary goal
may have become subsumed into something
much greater than you could have
imagined when it comes time to shift to
that greater purpose let your opponents
distract themselves with what they think
while you silently redeploy your efforts
to the final Victory as you put on your
armor to go fight for your children's
present and future remember these rules
and let them serve as a guide in how you
design your own approach but do not
limit yourself to only these rules think
through successes of the past and
history film literature business
politics and sports and shape your own
rules stick to them and pass them on to
others that is how we will win this
fight together this is Ian Pryor
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
I'm Emily compagno and this is the fox
True Crime podcast bringing you closer
to the story than you ever thought
possible subscribe at foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts these
are the stories that keep you up at
night
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes